oh boy this is so awesome
you guys don't know I'm obsessed with
backpacks like beyond of says I have so
many backpacks cuz I'm always looking
for the perfect bag but there's also
bags for different occasions depending
upon where I'm traveling how much gear I
have to have but this is like the
freaking most ultimate gear bag that I
have ever seen not only is this an
awesome bag but it was made by Peter
McKinnon and if you guys aren't familiar
with this channel make sure you guys go
check it out and also check out this bag
his videos are amazing and if you've
ever wanted to learn more about
cinematography photography or just
upping your videos in general definitely
go check his channel out but let's unbox
all its unboxed s I guess this isn't
really technically and I'm hugg saying
cuz I already opened the box and took it
out and looked at it so I guess it's
already unboxed here it is so let's just
open this thing up because there are so
many cool compartments honestly one of
the things that I love the most about it
is it's extremely high quality I'll put
a link in the description if you wanna
check out the Kickstarter and get more
information about it everything about it
is so thoughtful like the details just
like the little trimmings from like his
name and then like the pneumatic logo I
also have a couple other little things
that they set - they're great I love
little bags every time I travel
everything has a separate little
compartment it's so big you can't even
see me so let's start with this first
little zipper there's so many details
this is gonna be a 45 minute video so
it's got a small little pocket it's also
got a bigger one here it's got like a
little magnetic and let's go into this
big boy and we've got another little bag
I didn't open it yet it's a little
toiletry bag I'm standing up I'm getting
into this
I miss my standup unboxing table I think
I need to do a little reconfiguration
again this whole setup was supposed to
be temporary it's been a little bit of
temporary this is definitely too small
for my toiletries I will probably be
using this as a little gear bag
waterproof as well okay so this is nice
this has like a little strap here so you
can keep some things held down that's
nice little pockets here more zippers
and Miss also on my arse this whole
thing also unzips I loaded this thing up
with all of my things there'd be 500
pounds another great thing is it's also
accessible from the side so you've got
some side pockets here
oh there's goodies in there oh I'm not
ready for those yet let's flip this over
the laptop compartment is accessible
from the side and I like that this is on
the back too and this is super soft oh
my gosh this is somewhere that I want to
sleep
oh it has the little luggage strap
usually my carry ons consist of a
massive backpack like this and also a
little roller carry on said that I can
put the extremely heavy backpack on top
of the roller bag so they don't have to
actually carry it the fact that this has
that huge let's open up see what's in
here oh yeah this is nice there's so
much storage in here it's unbelievable
we've got more zippers over here another
slide pocket here you'll probably put an
iPad or even another computer I used to
travel with my service book so that I
could play fortnight on it and then my
macbook that is on what we got in here
this place to put like lenses or camera
body and this is so nice and protected
no way this is so Oh what is this did I
just discover another backpack inside of
the backpack so you can store your
camera your
and you can leave this in the car pack
the few extra little goodies that you
need I'm gonna cry this is such a great
idea
this is incredible my gosh I can go to
school watch box I need to go an
adventure immediately well let me put my
backpacks back inside my backpack and
look at this another little case put
things in I got your own horses
basically whatever and some more little
dividers so you can basically divide
this up into any configuration if
there's multiple dividers here and there
nice substantial quality who also got
case here for some nd filters SD cards
there's even another little side here to
put like a water bottle or tripod man
this is really freakin nice it's really
big I'm not a very big person I think I
could definitely fit my dog in there I
could probably fit myself if I scrunch
up enough this is also super exciting
because it's all a bunch of people that
had these at camera camp these are the
variable and D filters bipolar pro meet
Peter McCann in addition so we have the
six to nine stop and a two to five
this is so great I have been in
desperate need of some good nd filters I
need to stop recording and go somewhere
like I need to just leave I can't be
here anymore I can't be here I need to
go on an adventure and some stickers
we've got a reference chart these are
great I use polar Pro and D filters for
my drones so I'm super excited to check
this out a little cleaning cloth
Peter McKinnon one nonetheless why am I
still here why am I sitting here and not
on an adventure is the question that I'm
asking myself right now okay this is the
six to nine stops everything is it's a
little soft cases for travel even these
cases are awesome they're pretty
industrial I hope you guys enjoyed this
first little look at this backpack of
the parents are interested in more
information about it check out the
Kickstarter in the link below and also
the link to these polar Pro and D
filters and I have a couple of I guess
not that exciting travel adventures
coming up
but there are some outdoor shoots that
I'm doing and these are gonna come in
handy so you guys will probably be able
to tell when I'm using these outdoors
because usually we're filming in the
middle of the day and it's hot and it's
bright so can't wait to try those out I
will see you guys in my next video and I
[Music]